as the taliban celebrate their win in
afghanistan the pentagon is scratching
its big shiny head wondering what to do
with six billion dollars of unspent
funds what a headache let's have a
little look
that's right when the last set of us
troops turned out the lights and left
afghanistan literally there's now a big
pot of military funding just sitting
there gathering dust questions are being
raised by u.s lawmakers about how to
reallocate the six billion dollars worth
of funding that was set aside for the
afghan military you know that money that
was meant to bring peace back to
afghanistan but as soon as the now
defunct afghan army surrendered to the
taliban the funds that were funding them
can no longer fund because there's
nobody left to fund the department of
defense will work with the congressional
defense committees to determine the most
appropriate use for those funds
republican lawmakers want the money to
be spent on robust counter-terrorism
operations in the region worried that
the taliban who are now armoured up to
their eyeballs with all that new u.s
equipment that they bagged for the
bargain price of
absolutely nothing would have an
opportunity to do harm to the us and
their friends progressive groups however
think the money should be given to
afghan refugees fleeing the country now
the taliban hold the keys to the palace
redirecting these six billion dollars to
finance evacuations refugee resettlement
and much-needed humanitarian assistance
for example could spell the difference
between life and death for countless
afghans but the gop they're looking past
the spare six billion dollars they want
the white house to add a further 25
billion dollars to the already humongous
753 billion dollars that joe biden
requested for overall national defense
for the next fiscal year i mean you do
have to ask yourself that extra 25
billion think of all the new shiny
equipment the pentagon can make with
those sorts of digits the taliban must
be wetting their lips
you